[Applause]
hey guys it's max angelica and vadim and
today we are doing another blind camera
comparison with the new galaxy z43 the
s21 ultra and the iphone 12 pro max i
went out and i took a bunch of images
and vadima and angelica have not seen
them i lined them up randomly so they
are gonna have to choose which photo
looks the best before knowing the
results
and if you guys want to play along grab
a paper and a pen write everything down
and let us know your results in the
comments we'd love to know you guys
should absolutely do this to see which
phone you like best not what you're most
biased towards and a lot of people have
said that the cameras on this 1800 phone
they're not that great so today we will
find out are they really that terrible
compared to the flagship iphone and
samsung so here we have our first image
it's a selfie alright so right off the
bat i can tell that the one on the right
is just really bad because the sky is
completely blown out there's no sky at
all it's all white so that one's
instantly marked off so it's between the
left
and the center
and i don't know i'm i'm thinking the
center so far what do you what do you
think
i like the left one more honestly the
detail is really great on both the sunny
one does have some parts that are blown
out and it has this reflection spot
right here that's true i would pick the
left one and then maybe just bring up
the brightness all right and that one is
s92 samsung's and the iphone here is our
next one of this sign
wow that's pretty impressive and of
course one of these has a dedicated
telescopic lens yeah but you don't see
that big of a difference huh no it's a
massive difference really i i see it i
see it i see a lot of detail on which
one is the worst the right wins 100
incredibly detailed one on the left is
super soft one of the yeah that's a lot
of detail here it works worse so i was
expecting a bigger difference with that
lens but you can let's see
wow see
no way wow should we double check this
did you mess up so i just checked and
yes that is correct i don't know how the
z fold was better than s21 with that
telescopic camera crazy um
but it was maybe actually maybe i was
using the 3x on here this one has that
additional 3x oh really maybe i'm not
really sure and it's actually not called
the z flip 3.
it's the z fault we'll get it right
after that let's take a look at the next
one we have a nice shot here against the
bright sun all right looking at this one
it's definitely more difficult but right
off the bat i'm seeing that on the right
image there's a lot of i don't know
flaring or loss of contrast over here so
that one is eliminated and between the
left and the center i think i like the
one on the left because i guess
everything's brought up a little bit
more you can see more detail the only
difference i see between the left and
the center is just maybe the mids being
brought up a little bit more everything
else looks exactly the same detail looks
amazing so i'm going to go with the left
as well let's see wow
wait what do you guys have okay and
we'll keep that a secret don't show them
yet okay we'll wait till the end
and we have a portrait shot here using
the the longer lenses interesting i
don't like the one on the right it looks
really faded illuminated i agree between
these two they both look really good but
then i noticed that they po the portrait
mode messed up right here on the ring
you lose all that detail interesting on
the jacket right here you can see it
here but here it just looks
yeah faded not as detailed so the left
one for sure yep same as well because
there's a lot more detail especially in
the denim jacket in the hair and it's
just a killer shot that's like are you
guys going to keep it using the same one
i don't know but it's killer
so the z fold what's the iphone very
fast faded nothing for the iphone no
iphones yet no iphone come on guys this
is
this is how you guys know this is
unbiased blind comparison
all right we got some food up in here
which one would you want to eat most i
almost feel like the one on the left is
over saturated all of this kind of
blends together
so i think i'm going to go with the
right that's how i feel about the right
one i feel like the color is this one
don't look real it looks fake it weirds
me out so both samsung's actually have a
food mode
oh yeah it has a food mode yeah and it
suggests turning it on i'm going with
the right left and right
so here we have
against the sun yep center yep instantly
you can see in this back tree line you
can see a lot of those trees and colors
popping out you can't this one's
completely crushed why don't you just
like this one this one is a little bit
dark and it's soft look how faded it is
since you guys are giving your opinions
center center
[Applause]
we got a portrait of my boy here all
right so i saw some issues with the one
on the right you can see that the blur
effects didn't work
so i don't like that
and the one on the left i feel like it's
way too flat everything's just super
bright and flat i think i'm going with
the center i disagree i'm going to go
with the one on the left the one in the
center something about it throws me off
really something about it is weird it
looks fake i want if i wasn't playing i
would go with the one for the on the
right right i didn't notice that though
i like the extra detail here
a little more pop but you guys chose
yours let's see
s21 s2 what did you get thought we got
an iphone
i would have went for the right if it
wasn't for that that's true
all right and we have a close-up shot
what happened with this oh that is so
terrible yeah that didn't work at all
it's artistic guys
it's blurry
so this is out of focus
the one on the right is extremely like
cool and blue but also you lose detail
in here the skin almost looks like
purple yeah the one in the center kills
it z
the s21 didn't want to focus i tried
multiple times these ones are just like
click done that's super sharp it has a
it does have a huge sensor though maybe
that's why
all right we got a portrait shot with
some greenery the left one's contrast is
boosted way too much it looks really
weird at first glance the center one
looks amazing to me yes i would agree
too the center one it looks the most
natural the most kind of like a real
dslr camera because first of all it's
not crushed you know here is crushed
there's crush this looks natural and i
think the detail is more like you can
see fine hairs
and what i just noticed as well is over
here
it messed up and like kind of focused on
the ground that's a good point oh well
yeah i missed it and through here yep
centered
pretty dang that looks really good and
i'll mention it's blowing out right here
right probably oh yeah yeah yeah and
this is not well no it's impressive
that's cute good
all right
next
we have a nice contrasty scene for me
instantly the center i just pick up way
more detail right off the bat the one on
the right looks really faded loses a lot
yeah i think i'm also going to go with
the center because on the left it's kind
of like missing some contrast i think
[Music]
nice and another portrait shot this is
really difficult we got the bars we got
the sun we have depth yep i'm going with
the one on the left right away for the
same reason as before because her hair
has a lot of detail
compared to the other two it's crushed
so that is the main reason
i like the one on the left you could say
the same thing about the right though
because in alina's hair you see more
detail than a knees oh he says what i'm
saying i don't know in general i like
the left one more
this time without people all right the
one on the right is instantly
disqualified it's just kind of dark and
it also failed right here in the middle
of that little chain link
the algorithms are trained for people
not subjects but yeah all right i like
the one on the left the most you didn't
pick yet but to me the object stands out
a lot from the background the center one
it just looks way too flat yeah it
doesn't see you're right yep i would
agree it also stands out the most
exactly it has the most blur
s21 ultra so the iphone did the worst is
that what you guys were saying yeah it
did the worst
and we got us a selfie just like before
i don't like the one on the right
because it crushes all the hair detail
and between the left and the center it
is extremely difficult but if i look
very closely i think i do see more
detail especially in your beard that's
where i see a lot of it so i'm just
going to go with that one i'm definitely
going for the left one the center one
looks
way too warm it looks
unnatural and i feel like i'm not
getting as much detail on elena in the
back rather than over here so for the
left way more she looks a little bit
better
all right so okay we have z for home
so one difference here the reason why
lean is a little bit out of focus we
tried fitting a lot of people is this
shot was taken
with the z folds ability to take a
selfie with the rear main highest
quality camera which is why there's so
much more detail on me but at the same
time she's kind of blurred out she's
further back and then the trees almost
look like a portrait mode compared to
the other two and here we go we
watched some live music there instantly
left that's the only one where you can
get a lot of detail
looking at his pants the difference is
huge yeah i don't like how like the
light is behind his face but the detail
in general everywhere is much more crisp
like especially in the speaker grill
s21 ultra another selfie this is a
killer killer shot yeah
yeah yes this one is like
very like smeared out it failed
filters
it's like a it's like a painting filter
almost same thing with this one there
isn't nearly as much detail
wow
so this is the one shot i think i took
with this under display camera yeah it's
visible right there you could tell right
away it's pretty garbage it's pretty
good and we got this guy rocking out
there on the base i would say the one on
the right yeah you have the detail in
like his his shirts and everything
whereas this one's kind of like i don't
know faded and it's not as clean and
clear i agree you're right
s21 that's a good camera hey it's
catching up starting to catch up as the
light goes down let's see what happens
it's not the right this one might be
preference not the right for sure i just
i don't know it's just so gloomy and
just you can't really see much detail
out of it i think i like the one in the
center like that oh it's so weird all
right
12.
finally is this when it catches up
we'll see all right we got an ultra wide
here oh so much flaring what happened
here and here it's like a fail like all
this detail is gone and you got noise
and flaring everything there and here
garfield which one's
yeah the center s21 ultra wow all right
so the one on the right very faded the
colors completely faded i don't know
what happened and i think between these
two i do like the one
in the
center are you just making a rebellious
video no not i mean this the one on the
left i don't know it feels like it's
almost a little bit too bright in these
details like they're almost like blown
out ish like her dress in this
here i don't know why i just think the
white balance is more white or neutral
this looks warmer i don't know
well you guys both chose samsung so by
the way i clean off the lenses like
every single time to make sure it's
weird that's just it didn't kick the
contrast in there all right this is a
night mode shot i think it's the first
full using night mode yeah i don't like
the one on the left the color just looks
really off the one on the center seems
like it's having too much i don't know
over sharpening or hdr effect the one on
the right is incredibly clean like the
sky is clean the leaves are detailed the
back is deep oh you're right and look at
that
sorry i'm gonna choose no i agree do you
agree
whoa
interesting how different it is from
here look at that sky
right here okay wow all right we got a
portrait shot here oh wow instantly
crazy the center instantly yep
instant wind because this is just super
no detail yellowish detail's gone this
is insanely crushed
another so if you take a lot of
portraits keep the sunlight all right
lots of highlights this actually was
like almost black and this was super
bright so they all did good but what's
the best the right one is pretty
impressive out of all of them i'm
agreeing the right one because you have
more details here the lights aren't as
blown out and like weird so yeah you
guys are right and that is the 12 pro
max iphone yeah we got an ultra wide
here
instant wind center center if you look
at these neon lights or whatever oh
they're super clean and sharp whereas
they're like kind of smeared
blurred out on the other side look at
all the noise since you guys already
chose yeah look at all the noise here
yeah and all the flaring here the whole
thing
s121
oh sorry iphone sheesh we have a moody
alley here with the neon lights we have
other lights hung up here yep what would
you want to save in your phone for me
what about you instantly the one on the
right i know that it's darker around
here yeah but the subject is this it
looks great it's not blown out you can
see all the detail everything else is
yep i would agree because if you look at
these little lights here they're kind of
like smeared with like over sharpening
but here i like it the best it looks the
most natural and all the lights really
stand out
they're not blowing out look compared to
here amazing shot
s21
all right right off the bat the one on
the right is instantly disqualified it
just looks really bad between the left
and the the middle i think i do like the
one on the left because if you look at
the face facial features like the skin
you see more detail there like all the
little strands of hair i totally
disagree i don't like the left one this
right here in the center is all messed
up that's a good point it picked up the
details there i think the right one
looks really good it's pretty dark but
they look like the main subjects here
you're distracted by all this background
stuff and in the little details like in
the rings that looks beautiful looks
perfect s21 ultra and z fold three
iphone it looks like it focused here
okay if we look
and i'm kind of blurry and she's really
blurry and we have this night scene i
right away i like the left me too seeing
a lot more detail especially like if you
look here on this rock all those details
textures yeah these people
and we got a flag shot there yeah this
one's very obvious center life what is
garbage even though it has a 2.5 times a
lot of 2.0 that's bad a lot more detail
good algorithms i guess and this shot i
will say i was shocked it was completely
dark i could barely see anything and all
of them did a great job but there are
some differences this is pretty tough
the left and the center both look pretty
good but i think i'm gonna have to go
with the center i think i would have to
agree i don't like the right because
you're getting a lot of crushed detail
like in the wagon everywhere so i don't
like that one between the left and the
center i feel like the one on the left
kind of has like a very similar white
balance it's very warm in general and i
don't like that whereas the center one
has a lot of kind of dynamic color
contrast yeah so i like that too
z-fold z
fold very good it's kept up pretty nice
we got uh this is a selfie with night
mode it's super super dark and they're
really bright lights underneath that
bridge and on the clock tower this one
is definitely really tough i know that i
don't really like the center just
something off about it with like the
color and the detail
and between the left and the right even
though i do see like a lot of flaring
and stuff i think i still like the left
better than the right i just don't know
why but i feel like i like the
background of the center more this is
less blown out there's way less flaring
and you have detail on that clock tower
however in the space you have the least
amount of detail and that's what these
did great on and you probably can't see
from your angle very well but this one
has a lot of flaring like uh
and the last shot here
night time
ultra wide wow that's impressive left
yeah the left kills it in every single
way like the the clock tower with the
clock super detailed see texture in the
wood
again sorry iphone the iphone what
happened in addition because the iphone
usually takes about two seconds to take
a nighttime shot whereas these other
ones are about double like four seconds
even sometimes five seconds so you have
to be still but they did a really good
job combining all the shots so that is
the last photo that we have i haven't
been keeping track
of what you guys have written down yep
um
i'm very curious to see so you guys out
there if you guys are watching along if
you guys
took notes
voted pause this video comment down
below how many you voted for each one we
want to hear your guys's unbiased blind
results all right so
iphone has five
the s21 has 12 and the z fold has 13. so
iphone got crushed by both that is
incredible i don't think we've seen this
big of a gap yeah
and what's interesting is that
um i updated the software on all of them
too
latest software and z fold one for you
how about you angelica for me the s21
won out by one point twelve versus
eleven for the fold seven for the iphone
it's a little more even but still
yeah i think that
that's smoke so thank you yeah
realistically what did we learn from
this video unbiased blind comparison the
c-fold is not a bad camera oh yeah
people out there saying it's a mid-range
camera compared to flagship no
this camera is excellent
and really the only reason the one that
this the shots of this one were like the
telephoto shots right you want a few
telephoto shots so if you don't need
super zoom you don't really lose out by
going something like this so let you
guys let us know your opinions down in
the comments section below click that
circle above to help us reach 1 million
subscribers we would greatly appreciate
it check out one of those great videos
right over there and we will see you
guys in the next video
[Music]